in my animal misconceptions video I
casually mentioned that daddy long legs
aren't spiders and received a ton of
comments asking for clarification or
suggesting that it's not that simple
so I feel the need to clear things up a
little bit but first a disclaimer if
images of spiders make you uncomfortable
one you shouldn't have clicked this
video and two you should stop watching
right about now cutest spider ever right
when editing the video I decided to cut
out a daddy longlegs discussion and now
you'll see why to answer the question
our daddy longlegs spiders we first need
to know what are spiders and for that we
need the biological classification
system you should have learned in high
school
spiders are in the animal kingdom which
is a pretty broad class of life and not
helpful in narrowing things down the
phylum that concerns us are the
arthropods which are a subset of animals
with external skeletons segmented bodies
and jointed limbs the arthropods with
exactly eight legs and two body segments
are in a class called arachnids the name
where arachnophobia comes from and while
often used to mean fear of spiders there
are plenty of arachnids that are not
spiders such as scorpions and mites the
true spiders are a subset of arachnids
in the order of Aranea
what defines these as spiders are their
fangs the poison glands within them
their numerous eyes and their spinnerets
that allow them to make webs now that we
have a spider checklist on to the second
problem the name daddy longlegs means
different things in different places in
Australia this seller spider is called a
daddy longlegs which as an eight-legged
multi-eyed web-spinning member of a
rainy emai get an official spider it
also produces venom but then so does
everything in that bloody country where
I grew up this is a daddy longlegs
sometimes called a harvestman they have
just two soulless eyes can't web sling
and lack fangs and poison glands and so
failed a spider checklist and are in a
different order called Opilio needs it
was these that I had in mind while
making the video to make things more
complicated in my adoptive UK the
British called his crane fly daddy
longlegs
unlike the closely related Opilio knees
and Aranea the crane fly isn't an
arachnid but an insect the class of
arthropods with six legs and three body
segments and as if the name wasn't
ambiguous enough at this point there is
also a plant called daddy longlegs
for taxonomical completeness the plant
is over here in a different Kingdom but
because of the way life works even this
plant is distantly related to those
other daddy longlegs because plants and
animals are both eukaryotes which means
that their cells have complex structures
most notably a nucleus so to fully
answer the first question there are four
daddy longlegs three animals two
arachnids but only one spider among them
you